Barack Obama is convinced that women are
better than men they're just better at
an event in Singapore he said women are
indisputably better than men and
everything around the world would be so
much better if women were in charge
meanwhile testing his hypothesis in
Washington congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez couldn't figure out how to
enroll in her health insurance plan we
will examine how little Barack Obama
understands about men and women then
hallmark goes lesbian and The Huffington
Post gives us the dumbest article on the
Internet today all that and more on
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
all right mr. Obama you say that women
are much better world leaders than men
exhibit a to prove you wrong is actually
exhibit a Oh see you might say Barack
Obama was at this event in Singapore
unfortunately we don't have video of it
so we'll just have to read it I can try
to do my best Barack Obama voice he said
quote now women I just want you to know
you are not perfect but what I can say
pretty indisputably is you're better
than us better than men women are better
than men I'm absolutely confident that
for two years
if every nation on earth was run by
women you would see a significant
improvement across the board on just
about everything living standards and
outcomes and then he was asked if he was
ever considering going back into
political leadership and what he said
was he just wanted to step aside because
he's a man and he's getting older and
old men shouldn't be in politics quote
if you look at the world and look at the
problems it's usually old people usually
old men not getting out of the way
obviously he doesn't believe what he's
saying about men and women the evidence
of that is if he actually believed that
women are better leaders than men and
that men should step aside and let women
lead he would not have run for president
in 2008 he would have endorsed Hillary
Clinton the woman who was about to
become the first woman Democratic
nominee and the first woman president
and then he beat her pretty
unceremoniously so he doesn't really
believe it it's it's just pandering of
the highest sort and so he's getting a
lot of flack for this because it's so
disingenuous there are few people in
this world more unctuous than male
feminists they're just so ingratiating
they're just so flattering they're just
so early and that's what you're seeing
here it's and it's obviously untrue but
we'll get to what that means broadly for
our culture and a little bit for just
right now I want to focus on an aspect
of this that nobody's really talking
about which is his comments in Singapore
are sure just regular leftist
boilerplate men bad women good women
need to take over the whole world fine
they also seem to have a very practical
application to the 2020 Democratic
primaries
from the very beginning of this twenty20
primary people have asked Joe Biden why
Barack Obama hasn't endorsed him Joe
Biden was a loyal vice president for
both terms under Obama it seems like
Obama should come out and endorse his
guy he hasn't done it yet reportedly in
the early stages of Biden's campaign
Obama called him and said Joe you don't
need to do this really Joe you don't
need to do this just go back have corn
pop massage your leg hair ride off into
the sunset you don't need to to try to
become the president of United States
here he might be sending a message to
Joe Biden noting that Barack Obama does
in politics is accidental this is one of
the most calculating politicians that we
have seen certainly in our lifetimes and
I think in in recent history every
aspect of his career was geared toward
achieving the next goal making it to
become president I mean this guy became
president before he had accomplished
really anything he wrote two books both
about his favorite subject and he gave a
couple of speeches a couple of okay
speeches and a bunch of not that great
speeches he barely showed up for his job
as state senator in Illinois he was a US
senator for about five minutes and then
he runs for president he wins this is a
pretty calculating guy and he's pretty
good at the game of politics he's not
just accidentally making this last
comment if you look at the world and
look at the problems that's usually old
people usually old men not getting out
of the way who is the most prominent old
man in politics right now it's Joe Biden
he even seems older than Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders is also an old man but
Joe seems tired he's losing his train of
thought his teeth are falling out of
debates his eyeballs are exploding at
debates he seems very old and it would
appear here that in this whole comment
about men and women what he's really
saying is I'm leaning toward Elizabeth
Warren I know that I can't come out
against Joe Biden just yet but the times
are coming when I might have to do that
so get out of the way Joe just just a
little psychobabble that I'm reading
into this also let's not forget Hillary
Clinton is doing everything she can just
signal that she wants to get back into
this race so the men and women comments
well they're kind of stupid in the
Universal application bra
Obama is very likely sending a pretty
pointed message here we will get to test
his general theory of women being
greater statesman than men across the
board we will test that theory by
chatting with Maxine Waters and
Alexandria Cassio Cortes that should be
in illuminating but first I've got to
thank our friends over at wise foods you
know when government resources are
strained it can be days if not weeks
before you can get to fresh food and
water I live in Los Angeles where we
live on fault line more or less and so
earthquakes can happen we're always
waiting for the big one that's pretty
scary and no matter where you are in the
country looking around the political
scene you're probably thinking to
yourself gosh this can't last much
longer probably need to get prepared and
when when all that stuff hits the fan
you can't rely on someone else you have
to rely on yourself don't put yourself
in a situation where you need something
that you don't have get prepared today
the thing I love about wise foods is
they have very very high quality stuff
chef prepared internally and you get it
you put it in the pantry then you don't
think about it okay because all you'll
need is four cups of water it doesn't
even need to be hot you take the
contents of the pouch you pour them into
the water you stir it you cover it and
that's it about 15 minutes later you're
ready to go your family's ready to go no
matter the situation I'm hoping that we
this stuff never hits the fan we don't
need to worry about it but I'm just glad
that I can take down my stress levels
let that simmer until the end of this
month wise is clearing out inventory to
make room for the redesign packaging in
2020 which means that there are huge
savings available we're go to wise food
storage calm to take advantage of this
clearance save up to 70% off as always
shipping is free for my listeners when
you use the code NOLs canna wles at
checkout that's wise food storage com
use the code Knowles Cana wles get up to
70% off and free shipping now is the
time to do it get prepared today all
right Barack Obama says women
universally are better than men and if
women were controlling global politics
everything would be so much better let's
test that theory Maxine Waters was just
on CNN
how is stable and how wise did Maxine
Waters come off let's take a listen I
believe even though I don't have the
facts to prove it I believe that Putin
wanted to lift the sanctions he's always
wanted to lift these sanctions that were
placed on him because of his interfering
with an incursion into Crimea and so I
believed that they wanted to elect
President Trump and Trump I believe
agreed I will always believe this that
he agreed that if he got elected he
would lift those sanctions Churchillian
really Periclean you might say the
Oratory the the probing insight the
grand strategy from great great states
women like Maxine Waters I want to point
I mean I mostly just played that clip to
make fun of Barack Obama's point and
Maxine Waters
but I also want to point out that
virtually nothing of what Maxine Waters
just said there is true and she even
kind of recognizes it so she she comes
out and says look I don't have the facts
but here's my opinion which I love
actually like how guileless that is cuz
look I don't have any actual evidence of
my accusations but Trump is a bad guy
okay
and even though I don't have the facts I
know that he conspired with Vladimir
Putin alright and yeah I know we had a
two and a half year thirty two million
dollar investigation into whether that
happened or not and we determined
conclusively that it didn't happen but I
think it did and I don't have the facts
anyway but let me tell you something
American people Putin wants those
sanctions taken off and that's why
Donald Trump got elected and actually
he's been harsher on Russia than Barack
Obama was but never mind that orange man
bad that is the argument that's the
argument that Maxine Waters just made
and I'm not even really exaggerating him
so it would appear that Barack Obama's
theory is incorrect but let's look at an
another prominent States woman in
America Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
Alexandra Casio Cortez has been grilling
people testifying before Congress
she's been trying to push the greater
intrusion of the government into
employment and she's been trying to get
the government to force employers to
guarantee much more time off for new
mothers and new fathers here is the the
incredibly insightful argument that that
she makes to push her policy and
similarly your view on parental leave is
to let the market decide and I think
what we've seen here is that the market
has decided miss Shabo 80% of families
don't have access and workers don't have
access to paid parental leave correct
paid family leave so fair for a child or
as either seriously family member about
1/2 of moms don't have access to the
markets just said and how what is the
most common length of parental or family
paid family leave that you have seen in
general it's like six to eight weeks but
it really depends and there's not a
great there's there's not a great simple
that tells six weeks um do we know how
long puppies are allowed to stay with
their mothers after a dog has given
birth
I don't eight weeks Wow so the market
has decided that women and people who
give birth deserve less time with their
children than a dog and I think that
that at its core has shown that the
market has failed to treat people with
dignity and with basic respect and so
when that happens I think it's our job
as the public to redefine the rules of
society and to peep and to treat people
who give birth with the dignity that
they deserve thank you very much I think
there might be a few flaws here in the
analogy a OCS argument is if companies
are only giving people six weeks
parental leave that this is insufficient
because even dogs when they breed are
permitted eight weeks with their puppies
and so we're treating women and children
in this country worse than we treat dogs
now the question is
happens after the six or eight weeks
after the six weeks the the mother goes
back to work and still gets to keep her
child in the case of the puppies the
puppies are sold and given away there's
no and also dogs don't really raise
their puppies because they're animals so
there's that problem with it as well
but let's take a o'seas suggestion to
its logical conclusion
she says six weeks is not enough time to
raise your child so you give birth to a
kid you get six weeks off and then you
got to go right back to work and the kid
is left on his own and you got to pay
for childcare or something yeah I think
that's a horrible situation I think it's
a pretty bad bad problem so what would
what would AOC prefer would she prefer
eight weeks okay I mean if we're gonna
change the regulation to go from six
weeks to eight weeks that's not a huge
deal so fine okay
that's okay now is eight weeks enough to
raise your child of course not why not
twelve weeks so you get three months you
get 12 weeks parental leave and then you
have to go back to work is 12 weeks
enough No twelve weeks is not enough
that's three months what would be enough
then I think what AOC is trying to reach
for is saying I I think it should be the
case that women should be able to raise
their children and be financially stable
that's fine that's what we used to have
we used to have single-parent households
saying were single income households
rather but then there was a movement I
mean for many economic and social
reasons there was a movement to have
double income households okay you can't
have both at the same time you can't
simultaneously stay home with your child
for the entirety of that child's
adolescence and work full-time during
that period you can't have both
what a OC is acknowledging is there is
this conflict here people want to stay
on with their kids and they also want to
have this career and they think that
they can have it all and they don't need
to make any compromises of course you
have to make compromises that is life
these are finite goods that we're
talking about money is a finite good
time as a finite good you have to make
that decision and you're you're not
going to be able to fix that with some
government regulation unless you just
regulate that one parent can't go back
to work or unless you're gonna regulate
that the employer has to pay one parent
for the next 18 years but I don't think
that's gonna work at economically as
well or legally or constitutionally she
wants to have both sides of it not a
very good argument that she makes
mushiya is raising an interesting
question but I point that out also to
just knock down Barack Obama's argument
she then tweeted out her inability to
purchase health insurance so aoc tweeted
quote members of Congress also have to
buy their plans off the exchange they
are gold plans that are partially
subsidized that means I get to choose
she puts it in quotes between 66 complex
financial products this is absurd no
person should go without health care and
no one should go through this either no
one should go through the absolute
torture of getting to choose between
lots of different subsidized inexpensive
modern advanced health care plans it's
just awful this is a woman who needs
more problems than she has she doesn't
have enough problems and show so she's
complaining about privileged privileges
that she has including cheap good
abundant varied health insurance now I
fully grant that our health insurance
system is not completely simple but if
you are a leading American Statesman as
aoc somehow has become you should be
able to get health insurance you should
be able to purchase health insurance and
you can seems to be another piece of
evidence against Barack Obama's
contention that women are in all cases
at all times universal a better than men
and our politics would be so much better
if she let it but then I even have to
use an example from the Republican side
too to argue against Barack Obama's
point here we'll get to that in one
second first I've got to thank our
friends over at Nitsa and I've got to
give an important reminder for this
Christmas season everybody knows about
the risks of driving drunk right you
could get into a crash people could get
hurt or killed almost 29 people in the
United States die every single day in
alcohol impaired the
Crash's that is one person every 50
minutes don't do it
just don't do it I know people who have
been killed in drunk driving crashes I
know drunk drivers who have been
involved in those crashes we all do
right we all we've all known some at
least one person like that since high
school don't do it it can ruin your life
for what because you wouldn't take a cab
because you wouldn't call a rideshare
for the $10 it's gonna cost you to get a
cab you're gonna risk your life and
someone else's life don't do it
especially this time of year when
everyone's drinking and full of
frivolity and merriment even though
drunk driving fatalities have fallen by
a third in the last three decades that's
great news drunk driving crashes still
claim more than 10,000 lives a year
don't be part of that don't be a cause
of that don't be involved many people
are unaware that driving well hi can be
just as dangerous in 2015 42% of drivers
killed in crashes tested positive for
drugs and from 2007 to 2015
marijuana use among drivers killed in
crashes doubled okay driving well hi
it's just like driving while drunk it's
deadly so stop kidding yourself if
you're impaired from alcohol or drugs do
not get behind the wheel it's very easy
to call a ride do it don't put yourself
in that position if you feel different
you drive different drive high get a DUI
drive sober or get pulled over okay I
think we've pretty thoroughly debunked
Barack Obama's argument but just just
before we go away I have to identify a
very bad argument that a Republican
woman made on television this was made
by Carly Fiorina who I actually really
like I don't think it's a very good
argument Carly Fiorina says we have to
impeach President Trump but she might
vote for president Trump here's the
first part of that argument
do you believe president Trump should be
impeached and removed from office I
think he is going to be impeached and I
think he won't be removed from office
should he nice office if you were you
ran for Senate again you were in the
Senate it's a hypothetical I think it is
vital
that he'd be impeached whether removed
this close to an election I don't know
but I think the conduct is impeachable
okay he has to be impeached but maybe
not removed that doesn't make sense if
he should be impeached it's because he
committed an impeachable offense if he
committed an impeachable offense he
should be convicted of that infeasible
offense the whole point of the Senate
trial is to see whether or not he
actually did the thing that the house is
accusing him of doing if he actually did
the thing that the house is accusing him
of he should be convicted and therefore
he should be removed from office there's
no world in which you say he should be
impeached but not convicted then you're
saying the house should lie about him
the house should put up completely false
charges and then the Senate should knock
them down that doesn't make sense I
understand that there might be a
personal aspect here because Donald
Trump was very harsh on Carly Fiorina
during the 2016 campaign so that is
important context but the argument she's
making doesn't make sense and then it
makes even less sense a little bit later
when she says it is a vital that Trump
be impeached I don't know if he should
be removed oh and also I might vote for
him again did you Carly Fiorina vote for
president Trump yeah I actually did and
I've been very disappointed I did I felt
that Hillary Clinton also was corrupt
will president Trump get your vote in
2020 honestly it depends who the
Democrats put up and I won't go any
further than that
so impeachment comes about if a
president commits treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors these
are very very serious offenses that are
directly related to his conduct as
president and what Carly is saying here
is if he committed that that's really
bad it's so important that we we charge
him for it and we convict him and but
then not convict him for it and then
also I'll probably vote for him again
doesn't it doesn't make sense it's it's
an emotional argument and Donald Trump
evokes strong emotions and a lot of
people but as a matter of the
Constitution as a matter of the law as a
matter of philosophical and political
coherence that
does not make a whole lot of sense and I
really like carly fiorina
so that that's my knock against Barack
Obama's theory oh and also the fact that
he beat Hillary Clinton in 2008 so he
just does not believe the thing he's
saying why is Obama's statement done
it's done for a few reasons it is dumb
because he doesn't believe it it's dumb
because it's untrue and it's immature
this is the second point it's it's not
true that women are universally better
than men it's also not true that men are
universally better than women we can go
all the way back to the foundational
story about the difference between the
sexes in Genesis right you have Adam
Adam is created and then Eve is created
how is Eve created Eve is created in
Genesis when God pulls out one of Adam's
ribs and she is made from Adam's rib
this is an important aspect of the story
because if Eve had been pulled out of
Adam's head if Eve had been like a piece
of hair pulled out of his ear or
something that would put Eve above Adam
she's from the top of Adam if Eve had
been pulled from Adam's toe so on his
ankle or something that would put Eve
below Adam but she's pulled from the rib
from the center of Adam's body
women therefore have equal dignity with
men a crucial aspect of the story to
tell you about the relationship between
the sexes there have been great men
throughout history there have been great
women throughout history men are not
universally better than women women are
not universally better than men I mean
the argument that Obama's making is the
kind of argument someone would make an
elementary school boys are better than
girls girls are better than boys except
what he's doing is he's making the
opposite right he's not saying that I'm
a I'm a boy and therefore boys are
better than girls he's saying I'm a boy
and boys are really bad I'm I'm really
bad and therefore girls are so much
better and this brings us to the third
reason it's a dumb statement because
this sort of statement is white guilt
for the postmodern age all right it's
guilt about some immutable
characteristic that you have taken to
the most absurd postmodern extreme it's
male guilt we'll get to that in just one
second first
we can do a lot more - first I got to
thank our friends over at Daniel's
christmas is coming alright it is right
on the doorstep you need to get a
Daniels briefcase I've had a lot of
really nice briefcases in my life
ostrich skin and all kind of crazy stuff
Daniels is my favorite briefcase I've
ever had it's designed in New York City
with working professionals in mind it is
a bag built for real life it is made
from high-quality durable Italian
leather they've even upped their game I
didn't think that was possible but
recently they've upped their game the
leather is so so good the design is so
simple there's no flashy logos you're
not gonna walk around looking like
you're a hip hop star or something it is
a timeless style that works with you
wherever you are in your career I love
this bag because the price point is
really really accessible it's it's far
less expensive than a lot of name-brand
designer bags and yet the Daniels bag is
better it looks better it functions
better you could get this right when
you're out of college or I please do not
show up to the office with a backpack on
I'm begging you don't don't put yourself
through that don't degrade yourself like
that use a briefcase you're an adult you
could use it at the early part of your
career or you could use it when you're
well established I love this thing and
they've got really cool designs on the
inside just that classic East Coast
style now as as modern design makes
everything look hideous there is Daniels
that still looks terrific this week my
listeners can get fifty dollars off
their Daniels briefcase at Daniel's NYC
comm by using promo code Michael mi CH
AE L at checkout that is fifty bucks off
one of their leather briefcases plus
they offer free shipping free returns
and free exchanges treat yourself treat
a friend or a loved one this holiday
season with a one-of-a-kind gift that is
Daniels NYC comm promo code Michael mich
L for 50 mi CH AE LM was misspelled by
name for $50 off a handcrafted
high-quality leather briefcase with free
shipping all right the third reason
Obama's line is so ridiculous here is
because it's white guilt for the
postmodern age it's it I've always
thought white guilt is so ridiculous you
feel bad because of the color of your
skin that's just as dumb as feeling
really proud because of the color of
your skin it's just a fact that you were
born with and you move on right
this is taking that to a logical extreme
saying because I'm a man I'm really bad
and forget let's say Barack Obama
actually did believe it let's say Barack
Obama actually to drop out of the 2008
presidential race and back Hillary
Clinton because she's a woman that he's
a man that doesn't make any sense
men are important the world wouldn't
function without men men are half the
population men have accomplished plenty
of good things they have something to
bear to bring to the table a physical
strength and their brains work a little
differently than women that's just the
way it is I know that for a long time
liberals would not allow you to grant
that men and women have different
personalities generally speaking but
actually now because of the transgender
movement they are admitting that again
because they're saying that one proof of
transgenderism is that transgender men's
brains function differently than regular
men's brains or women's brains they make
very complicated arguments we know that
men and women are different the world
needs both of them you can either have a
politics that looks at difference that
looks at variety and says if two things
are different one of them must be bad or
you can have a politics that embraces
variety that loves the world that loves
the diversity of the world and says
women have something to offer and men
have something to offer too but Barack
Obama is simply too immature and his
politics are too shallow
speaking of shallow politics this
impeachment thing could not be working
out better for the president we've been
talking about it a bunch this week so I
only want to get to a couple points here
but I have to mention them you know
Carly Fiorina summed it up she said I
think Trump is a terrible guy I think he
should be impeached but yeah I might
vote for him I think a lot of people
agree with that according to a
Quinnipiac poll which is a notoriously
left-leaning poll president Trump now
has the highest approval rating that
they've ever recorded for him since he
entered office and that is after all of
this impeachment business they could
impeach him in the house tomorrow
Democratic Representative ELISA slot can
of Michigan she's a Democrat who's
supporting impeachment she just went
down to do a town hall here's how her
constituents greeted her they weren't
too happy
my logic and I know it's clear that we
don't all agree but I'm gonna walk you
through my logic in an attempt to be
transparent and I know I knew from the
very beginning that this was going to be
a controversial decision right that was
something I understood from the very
beginning but for me it was something
that was important to do she's just
gonna keep on rolling they're just gonna
keep on shouting by the way this wasn't
just one or two people in the audience
it's not one of those kind of staged
protests it doesn't look like looks like
this is a huge swath of the audience if
not the majority support for impeaching
President Trump is down we talked about
yesterday how it's down in the general
electorate according to CNN it's also
down among Democrats that's even
according to the CNN poll according to
that poll support for impeaching and
removing Trump is now down to forty five
percent down from fifty in a poll that
was conducted just a couple weeks ago
CNN says opposition to impeachment
removal stands at 47 percent up from 43
percent in November and among Democrats
support for impeachment and removal has
dropped from 90% to 77 percent so you've
got a double-digit drop in support for
impeachment and removal among Democrats
Schiff Pelosi Nadler they could not have
blown this in a more hilarious and
dramatic way how are the mainstream
media reporting on this here's just from
Yahoo News I love this quote from Yahoo
News they're saying that Trump is Teflon
despite all this scandal he keeps
surging and his approval ratings and
support for impeachment keeps dropping
they say inoculated by scandal from
Andrew Johnson who got impeached in 1868
no president has exactly enjoyed the
notoriety of being impeached Richard
Nixon resigned over the Watergate affair
just before he could be impeached while
Bill Clinton fought bitterly to avoid
being convicted by the Senate in 1999
but Trump a veteran of scandals comes
into the or D
uniquely ready after all he's already
ridden out allegations of sexual assault
and other misconduct by two dozen women
over the years he has withstood a
two-year probe by a special prosecutor
into whether he was wittingly or
unwillingly getting election help from
Russian agents the article goes on I
just want to show you the language here
he's withstood all the scandal he's
somehow made it past all of that scandal
let's rewrite that let's rewrite that
more honestly a bunch of women have
accused Trump of things that none of
them have ever proved despite decades of
trying a bunch of bureaucrats tried to
overturn the 2016 election and Democrats
abetted this process by spending thirty
two million dollars over two and a half
years and they still had no evidence
that Trump committed any crimes with
Russia it's not that Trump has somehow
miraculously survived all these scandals
it's that the scandals were made up they
had nothing they had nothing on the guy
but of course if Trump were a Democrat
the article would read very very
differently but I think articles like
that reactions like that from the
mainstream media or why you're seeing
those numbers drop even among Democrats
they just don't want the dishonesty all
right we got to get to hallmark going
lesbian we've got to we've got to get to
Megan Fox raising her her children
non-gendered and vegan and we will get
to the dumbest article on the internet
today first I've got to say goodbye to
our friends at Facebook and YouTube
because we got a whole lot more to get
to or we've got a few cultural stories
here that tell us something about the
nature of liberalism we've got so much
important work to get to but you got to
go to daily wire.com you and me the end
reclaim and show the ben shapiro show
the Matt Walsh show it test questions in
the mailbag you get another Kingdom by
the way the mailbag is coming up on
Thursday so get your questions then and
you get the leftist here's tumblr most
important of all especially as we get
into the Christmas season as we move
into winter because those leftist tears
are gonna freeze and they're gonna turn
to hail and sleet and you do not want to
be caught out without your Tumblr to
catch all of them go to daily wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
hallmark has gone lesbian and it tells
us something about liberalism it tells
us something specifically about
supposedly value-neutral
liberalism what happened the Hallmark
Channel on Sunday decided to reinstate
an ad for featuring a same-sex couple
getting same-sex married on the network
so there's this wedding planning company
named Zola and they were featuring a
same-sex marriage ceremony in the
commercial and Hallmark Channel is very
conservative very traditional the whole
audience is traditional family values
it's you know absolutely milquetoast
1950s kind of values and so they said
we're not going to run this commercial
of people redefining marriage and this
created a big backlash and they've since
apologized Hallmark issued a statement
they said quote Hallmark will be working
with GLAAD the Gay and Lesbian Alliance
Against Defamation they will run the
commercial featuring these two women
kissing and and walking down the aisle
everybody's so happy on the solla they
will better represent the LGBTQ
community across our portfolio of brands
the statement goes on the Hallmark
Channel will be reaching out to Zola to
re-establish our partnership and
reinstate the commercials our mission is
rooted in helping all people connect
celebrate traditions and be inspired to
capture meaningful moments in their
lives
anything that detracts from this purpose
is not who we are we are truly sorry for
the hurt and disappointment this has
caused and did Zola say oh thank you so
much for putting her commercial back on
know that pushed the issue harder they
said we were deeply troubled when
hallmark rejected our commercials for
featuring a lesbian couple celebrating
their marriage and we really we are
relieved to see that decision reversed
we're humbled by everyone who showed
support not only for Zola but for all
the LGBTQ couples and families who
express their love on their wedding day
every single day what this shows us is
that liberal
is not neutral so much of the debate we
have going on right now I'm the
conservative circles between the
Conservatives and the libertarians is
over whether liberalism is neutral the
libertarians tell us liberalism is
neutral it's a neutral playing field and
the Conservatives can fight it out and
the leftists can fight it out but at
least one of neutral liberalism and what
the Conservatives are saying is
liberalism isn't neutral liberalism has
a very specific and radical set of
values some of which we disagree with
and so if we're playing on the playing
field of liberalism we're going to lose
because we're playing by the other
team's rules they make the rules and we
will end up at their conclusions and the
Conservatives here are right the
disagreement is over the definition of
marriage in all places everywhere on
earth read all of history until about
seven or eight years ago people believed
that marriage was between husbands and
wives they believed that sexual
difference had an important role in the
definition of marriage and there are
plenty of other important relationships
that you'll have in your life but they
aren't marriage marriage is a specific
one then we decided to radically
redefine marriage at the level of the
Supreme Court to include monogamous
same-sex couples so it still has to be
monogamous but it's sexual difference
goes out the window
that's the disagreement that we're
having here and the Hallmark Channel
more than any other channel on
television is this really traditional
normal conservative Family Values kind
of use whatever euphemism you want
they're a conservative channel and
they're not allowed to be a conservative
channel anymore because liberalism will
not tolerate it because liberalism is
not neutral okay and and that is a
dishonest premise to begin with I think
about it even in in the schools right in
the schools they say public schooling is
gonna be completely value neutral we're
not going to instill values on people
we're just going to teach them the facts
okay and teach them how to think and
then they can come to their own
conclusions so we're gonna get the Bible
out of schools we're not going to permit
people to pray in schools and that's
gonna be neutral that isn't neutral
because what you're saying is atheism is
neutral that's not
neutral position it's the a very small
minority view held by people throughout
all of history and and it's the opposite
of theism it's the opposite of say a
broadly Christian worldview you could
call it the judeo-christian worldview
you could call it the theistic worldview
whatever you want to believe in God and
not believe in God are opposite opinions
to say that not believing in God is
neutral is to basically give the
argument to the secularists from the
beginning to believe that marriage has a
definition and it involves sexual
difference is the opposite as saying
marriage does not involve sexual
difference if we now have to play on the
playing field of marriage has no sexual
difference then there's no disagreement
the left is one before the debate
already began even begin that is what
we've seen the left do time and time
again and it's why there's a
conservative reaction against this if we
can't have the Hallmark Channel if we're
not allowed to express our completely
mainstream opinion our opinion that
everybody has always held everywhere if
we can't express that on the Hallmark
Channel if we can't express it in
chick-fil-a the the one stal word
conservative fast-food company then the
whole culture is lost shows you that
corporate America is just gonna follow
liberalism along as long as we accept
liberalism to be neutral which it is not
another great example of this Megan Fox
Megan Fox is raising her son's
non-gendered gender undefined and vegan
she's raising her three sons that way
and she just talked about this with
People magazine she has three boys three
five and seven years old and she says
she's raising them to be quote who they
were born to be she goes on it's about
releasing control right that's all it is
it's allowing them to be who they are
and relinquishing control because they
were born to be who they are it's my job
just support that process not to get
involved in micromanage and mold them
into what I think they should be but
this isn't about releasing control
that's the lie of value-neutral
liberalism what the left wants you to
believe is we're not coercing you into
anything
we are simply letting you be and make
your own decisions
that's what the liberals believe it's
what the leftists believe that's what
the libertarian right-wingers believe
just back off and we're just letting you
make whatever decision you want that's
not really how it works
it's just coercion in another form first
of all a parent's job is not to just let
her kids run around and do whatever they
want a parent's job is to raise the
child to educate the child to teach the
child right from wrong to teach the
child how to behave if you let the kid
run around that's just a dereliction of
that Duty but moreover if you raise the
kid and say I'm not going to tell you
that you're a boy I'm going to tell you
you're neither a boy nor a girl and you
can make your own decision those are two
forms of coercion okay well one is one
is coercing them to believe the truth
one is coercing them to believe a
fantasy
same thing with veganism if you if you
teach it if you cook food for a kid you
make him a turkey dinner
you are coercing the child to eat meat
if you refuse to make meat for a kid and
you have a mead kale and avocados for
dinner every night you are coercing the
child to be a vegetarian but either way
this involves some coercion that's
because all of Education involves
coercion that's because this liberal and
libertarian and classically liberal and
whatever term you want fantasy that were
just atoms floating in space and we can
never be have our preferences impinged
upon is a fantasy we live in society
there is no such thing as the state of
nature there is no such thing as
wandering around without any ties to
community you were born into a family
that will involve some coercion you were
educated education is an intrinsically
coercive action you live in under a
government the government will coerce
you it has that's the definition of
government and the question that
conservatives are asking is if there is
going to be coercion is it going to be
toward reality or is it going to be
toward unreality are we going to force
conservative TV channels to take on
radical leftist ideology or or are we
going to insist upon
a more traditional definition of
marriage you have to define your terms
and when you define something you are
necessarily excluding other options we
got to get to the dumbest article on the
Internet today before we before we head
out this is from the Huffington Post
it's actually right on our theme it's on
the same kind of theme Huffington Post
I'm choosing not to have kids because I
care about the environment it's by an
author named Mariana Keane the article
begins many people believe it's their
duty to have children but for me the
opposite is far more accurate I feel
it's my responsibility not to have
children as part of a collective effort
to respond to an unsustainable
population size we've heard this story
for decades and decades we heard it
especially in the 1970s during the
environmentalist movement really gaining
steam during the Earth Day movement you
had major scientists some of whom are
still working at Stanford University
right now who said within 10 years there
will be mass starvation the population
will just get too big financial
resources will not be there and people
will die off in the millions every
single year and guess what happened
between 1970 and today the world
population has doubled guess what else
has happened poverty has dropped
dramatically we are richer and fatter
than ever there are abundant resources
we're doing great it's just debunked but
it hasn't been debunked by these
left-wing ideologue who are writing at
The Huffington Post they say the world
population is growing by approximately
83 million people every year due to a
high birth rate and they falling death
rate and this is having a devastating
impact on the planet so first of all in
the West the the birth rates are falling
I mean if this woman is living in the
West if she's living in America as it
would appear she is our birth rate is
well below replacement levels so she not
only can't have kids she definitely
should have kids if she wants the
population to even remain the same as it
is but she doesn't she it would
he or she wants it to decline the
conclusion of her argument though is if
she's really worried about the
populations that are exploding all
around the world she's saying that brown
people in Africa shouldn't have kids
she's saying that people in East Asia
and South Asia shouldn't have kids she's
saying ethnic ethnic minorities in the
United States outside of the United
States should not have children that's a
pretty weird argument it's a pretty
awful thing to say but the left always
does this they want to stop human
flourishing they want to use less they
want to work less they want to consume
less they want to live less she writes
this is something I've been ruminating
over for a long time but the intense
pressure I felt as a woman to have
children has still etched away at my
thoughts right it's a pressure that is
biological and it's comes from your
conscience and it comes from society of
course and it comes from our tradition
and it comes from our nature you want to
have kids the left does this all the
time they want to decrease the human
population through abortion through
euthanasia through population control
through contraception you're seeing a
theme here and when you realize that
that we're spirits not animals when the
great forces are on the move in the
world to quote Winston Churchill you
realize there might be a spiritual
component here and if if there's one
political ideology that's constantly
saying kill people before they're born
kill people when they get too old kill
people if you find them a little bit
defective don't have children don't give
birth don't procreate that is probably a
pretty wicked ideology and it gets the
the moral situation exactly backwards
why would you not have children what she
says is I'm not going to have children
to save the planet the planet is just a
big rock okay the planet is here for us
we're the ones who enjoy the beauty of
the planet we're the ones who enjoy the
beauty of this whole world do you think
that the deer are gonna worry about
population control do you think that
animals running around in the wild that
bunny rabbits are worried about
population control absolutely not do you
think the trees are worried no the trees
don't have fears it's us
it's about us we are stewards of our
environment all right and that is how
we're going to lead I I would say also
I'm just checking this writers sex ah
yes what appear to also disprove Barack
Obama's argument universally and across
the board you know the other just before
we go I have to get this other this
other point in here in 2008 Barack Obama
was running against John McCain and
Sarah Palin it was a ticket of two men
versus a man and a woman he didn't give
it up then I think if I had to draw one
conclusion
from all of this I think that these
leftists don't really believe the thing
that they're saying I think maybe they
have ulterior motives I think they might
be getting the world wrong that's our
show come back tomorrow web a whole lot
more in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael an old show see you
then
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis clever and Robert Stirling our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director havel we douse key
editor and associate producer
Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson
hair and makeup Jeshua alvera production
assistant McKenna waters the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]